Leave me alone!
All I said was we should bail on the hike!
I didn’t mean us in general. I just meant the hike!
You don’t want to make our relationship better?
Our relationship is fine!
What’s that?
Church bells?
Schmigadoon?
Welcome to our little town!
Where friends are all you meet.
It must be something they do for tourists.
Hey everyone!
Hey there Pete!
Can we go now?
Already?
What?
We can’t leave. It’s like magic. We’re in an actual musical.
Please god no.
Everybody!
They said we’re only here ‘til we found true love. Do you think this is true love?
What does that even mean? Who knows what Schmigadoon thinks is true love?
Which of you ladies wants to cross this bridge with me?
You want to try with other people?
What a beautiful couple you two make.
Stop it, you are stunning. Compared to you, I’m a barefoot mess.
AH!
Let’s just go find your shoes, shall we?
We’re stuck here forever.
You’re just going to give up?
We’re smart. We found our way out of Ikea. We’ll find a way out of here.
Ladies, can I get a cackle?
We’re in a musical okay? Nobody gets killed in a musical.
Except Oklahoma.
And Carousel, and South Pacific. Oh, hello, West Side Story!
That’s all the musicals!